good morning we start with breaking news
and new footage has just been released
that shows the moment a Russian fighter
jet collided with an American drone the
U.S Air Force says two Russian aircraft
conducted an unsafe and unprofessional
intercept of the unmanned drone in
international airspace over the Black
Sea on Tuesday the Russian jets are
accused of dumping fuel on the Drone and
striking its propeller causing damage so
severe its remote pilot was forced to
bring it down we are joined here now by
air Vice Marshall Shaw Bell and uh as
Sean greatsy as always I guess just
first and foremost run us through what
we think happened and what the US said
happened yesterday with this particular
this particular case yeah good morning
wolf it's it is worth said in the
context of this because it's it's a
pretty dramatic footage isn't it in
response to the Russian invasion of
Ukraine NATO has been reinforcing the
Eastern flank of NATO operating a lot of
military aircraft fairly close to
Ukraine airspace and Russian airspace
all to design to deter further Russian
aggression along the way but those that
same aircraft can now provide eyes and
ears over the whole of Ukraine and
Crimea and of course with the Western
support for Ukraine that has of drone on
an intelligence and surveillance Mission
the Americans have admitted that was
intercepted by two Russian su-27
flankers at the East and the West
routinely operate so they're the
Lancashire and they're routinely
intercept each other's aircraft that's
why we have quick reaction in the alerts
in the UK we're reporting the other day
about the same sort of thing in Estonia
but they normally just handle very
professionally on this particular
occasion obviously the Drone is unmanned
the Russians intercepted it and of
course the um the U.S reported that the
there was fuel dumping going on and
ultimately they said that the propeller
had been damaged by the Russian faster
aircraft which ultimately ended up in
Downing of that aircraft and so they've
obviously now the Americans released
footage from how they saw will unfold it
I mean first why would they release this
footage and what does it really tell us
well the footages here and I think part
of the reason they would be doing that
well first of all it takes a while
because you've got to declassify it
normally these video footages are
covered in lots of really detailed um
numbers
um it's worth pointing out the funny
footage is looking backwards at the at
the tail of the airplane you can see the
propeller because this is pushed Along
by the propeller from the back the
Russian fighter
um it's worth pointing out that these
drones normally operate about 200 knots
and at those speeds they're quite
maneuverable the Russian fighter you see
here is normally operating at two or
three times that speed so it's not very
maneuverable at those speeds and what
you're seeing there is the Russian is
almost certainly trying to dump fuel
over the engine and by doing that by
coming from underneath the Drone using
its wash to wash the fuel into the
drone's engine and therefore take it out
the trouble is as he pulls the aircraft
up he hasn't got the aerodynamics
because he's not flying very fast and
therefore washes his way gets very close
to the body of the Drone and almost
certainly Just Clips the propeller now
almost certainly from a military
perspective that this is not intentional
it's intentional to dump the fuel it's
not intentional you would not as a
fastjet guy when I flew Jets you would
not want to risk your aircraft by
clipping another aircraft the
consequences could be quite severe the
trouble is with the propeller damaged
unfortunately it's a pretty high
high-tech bitter kit and without that it
was down catastrophic for the Drone
almost certainly damaged the aircraft
what we don't know is what damage is
obviously the Russian aircraft is manned
so it's a it's a significant risk reward
trade-off there for the Russian plane I
mean it seems like they achieved their
aim though one way or another to bring
down the Drone there's sort of maybe
uproar's too strong a word but but
disappointment from the western side
that they did this can we be that
surprised or annoyed by that action I I
get that you're saying it's
international waters but it is the Black
Sea not the Atlantic there is a war on
near there that NATO supposedly isn't
involved with so I mean I I guess is it
understand mandible that the Russians
would test the boundaries of what's
International airspace during these
sorts of times Well two things first of
all I would probably just told you to
count slightly I don't think I think the
Russians were having to go at bringing
the interfering with the mission whether
they actually wanted to bring the Drone
down or not it's another matter if they
wanted to bring it down just use the
bullets just fire at it
um I think this was almost certainly an
incompetent Russian pilot that
accidentally clipped the aircraft and
took it down but it's your broader point
I think this was International airspace
and under international law you can't
any act against another platform is an
act of War now let's be clear I I take
your point that this is right close to
the Battle Zone but Russian aircraft are
routinely penetrating you at UK airspace
and we don't routinely go up there and
shoot them down there is a a
professional way that each side tests
its defenses this was not in Russian
airspace yes it was close to Russian
airspace but Russian airspace provides a
buffer zone before it gets to Russian
territory and this was evidently an
accident the trouble is with this whole
all going on so you see the Black Sea
the remnants of the Drone will have gone
down there that's dominated by the
Russians and it'll be very difficult for
the Americans to help to retrieve their
drone at the end of this
um but I just think it just demonstrates
as the the this accident shows the
unintended consequences of an escalation
intentions that could have catastrophic
consequences for escalation of the war
yeah really interesting Sean thanks for
the for the context to those quite
incredible pictures Sean Bell as always